hey everyone it's Mike whatõs and
welcome to the other floats market
analysis for Tuesday August 22nd 2017
and you know after her the we had nice
game today
you know we had you know these last
couple weeks have been pretty
interesting we're getting these small
little gains doji candles each day and
then we get like a big sell-off on a
Thursday so it's nice to see a nice rise
of about 1% in the in the Dow but other
than that you know later this week we
got Janet yellen's speech and we have
some other economic data coming out at
the end of the week for you know oil
ended up today little change 47 65
around there but you know I did have
some quite nice moves and I'm going to
want to get a little bit in depth in
crude oil today I had a request try and
talk a little bit more about crude
honestly I won't focus more on you know
the currencies the SPS in the bonds you
know I don't know why that is I think
they'll probably being from Chicago I
used to work on the CNE floor you know
I'm always been partial to the
currencies and you know crude oil is a
New York product me I don't know you
know but that's why I sort of focus on
the Chicago products a little bit more
than than crude but honestly though
today you know today was a beautiful day
for for trading crude oil in terms of
you know if you watch the Delta if you
watch the order flow so you know I'll
try and talk a bit about that today so
before I get started the disclaimer this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only should not
be considered a solicitation to buy or
sell a futures contract or make any
other type of investment decision
futures train contain substantial risk
and is not for every investor and
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment risk
apples money that could be lost without
jeopardizing one's financial security or
lifestyle only risk capital should be
used for trading and only those with
sufficient risk capital should consider
trading past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future results
again you know if you can't afford to
open an account or if you're just barely
scraping by you know might want to
consider waiting until you get some more
money um you know I know you know people
sometimes come up to me like like
they're in a race against time like oh
you know I need to make X amount of
money over the next three months or
gotta go find a job well that's not the
recipe for success in trading right it's
not like oh I have to become successful
in three months no you know you can you
can I mean you know people do be you
know people sort of have this inherent
trading trait gene in them that you know
once they start trading you know it
asserts itself but you know most people
know it's going to take a little bit
time got to understand the market
don't come in don't believe the hype
thinking that you know you can make you
know ten thousand dollars in two weeks
trading people do but you know it's rare
you know people that make ten thousand
you know they usually start with fifty
thousand and at the end of three weeks
are left with ten thousand but but
anyway you do tools I using this
presentation are the order post trader
and a delta scope okay I'm trying to
keep it real right keep it realistic I
don't want to inflate your expectations
beyond you know what be realistic right
be realistic you're not going to become
you know CEO of Amazon in two months
you're not going to be like that you
know it takes time you got a you got to
work you know with anything in life
right it takes work it takes effort you
got to put in the effort on your part so
that said let's take a look I'll start
with crude done but find my chart give
me a sec here oh I need a footprint
chart just really quick you know just
could again I'm going to talk about it
with order flow but again this is the
eight range chart bar chart using the
Delta scalper you see it's got suet you
know even though we've ended up today
pretty much unchanged around forty seven
sixty five that area down in here I mean
we had some nice movements from forty
seven forty all the way up to forty
eight fifteen back down back up back
down back up back down Delta scalpers
picking you know almost gone say every
turning point but it's picking you know
the good ones it's got this nice move
here it's got another nice move here
another nice move here this one's okay
this one's okay but there was some like
said you know there were some nice
movements today even though we ended up
the day
pretty much around around hunched okay
now just bear with me here what the heck
happened to my chart let's apply the
problem when I've got about 50 charts
open sometimes they can get buried and
here we go okay so let's go back here
make it so you can see it properly now
crude oil right now I'm a big fan of
trading crude oil you can trade it
during the evening on say the evening
session but during the early morning
session right the European session you
can trade it there's a lot of are
between Brent crude and WTI and you know
actually that there's in Asia and Europe
there's a lot of crude oil traders you
know Singapore is a hotbed for crude oil
trading a lot of people don't realize
that but you know they trade not only
crude but they trade all the products
they trade you know even you know fuel
oil gas oil everything out of that of
Singapore so you know the and 2:00 in
the morning is just the afternoon in
Singapore so you get a lot of activity
once the European counterparties start
coming in as well so you can see how the
volume is here at 2:00 in the morning
you know you're trading decent-size on
these bars look at these volumes 800 600
700 so it's legitimate it's decent it
can be traded at that time so these
people say well I got a job you know I
wanna learn training but you know what
what kind of trade well if you're in the
u.s. and you have a job get up a few
hours earlier watch the crude oil
markets ok so what we got let's watch
the Delta here do anything interesting
not really yet now this was interesting
here at this high so boom we hit this
high here at 4:00 in the morning 4:00 in
the morning sort of corresponds with the
old ice IPE Brent crude oil opening so
sometimes you're going to get it again
you know you had the Mid Eastern people
trading you know as was well around
these times you see how the volume is
picked up quite nicely a thousand at
each level here but you get this bar
right on this high ok
this bar was interesting here you got a
small Delta 20 at one point this is
quite strong negative as minus 500 and a
positive 20 then you get this bar here
there's no min Delta it's all max Delta
it's all positive Delta but he was 597
it ended up at 159 that's a bearish sign
especially when you're at a high okay
because what is telling you is always
buying early they were buying buying by
an aggressive buying yet almost close to
600 positive Delta the bar turned you
ended up with only 159 next bar so
you're not convinced yet you get a small
Delta one okay this coincidence says
just one it could be zero it could be
ten but it's small again it's kind of
back in 412 minus 86 in the Delta maybe
you're not convinced yet
look at this bar here - 357 now you
should be convinced the selling is
coming in you know you sort of saw some
selling in here it's hidden though it's
hidden in the Delta you can't see it if
you're just looking at the headline
Delta you just see 150 90 volts positive
Delta okay but if you analyze the Delta
a little bit deeper look at the max
Delta the min Delta you'll notice it was
a strong max Delta early in the bar 597
and it only ended up at 159 so it gave
back what is that about 450 Delta's you
know the came in late an additional 450
net sellers
okay next bar yeah one of those new bars
you know nothing special but then this
next bar strong negative Delta 357 if
you're not convinced yet this is the
Delta surge giving you a sell signal
here strong Delta 501 so you get you got
a shift up here you got to change from
strong positive to is starting to change
to negative it did quite didn't get
there there wasn't enough volume here
you know honestly if there was another
200 Lots hidden in here buried in here
on the bid you would have ended up with
negative Delta that's high anyone had a
divergence but you know there wasn't a
bar ended up and we're trading lower
here trading lower here this bars is the
sign saying hey idiot don't miss this
you know it's it's
sellers have taken over right it's the
others it just drops off here very thin
volume it's just moving for
faster - boom sellers came in whacked it
lower and so you could move what happens
you you know 47 this area 47 76 is
assuming you know it takes you all the
way to this bar here - to pick this up
okay but if you pick it up here what
happens you know if you're getting short
in this bar you know around the 7776
area 75 what happens is the trades will
retrieve lower boom boom boom lower down
into the you know the 40s so from the
70s down to the 40s now so watch what's
happening as you're getting down here
near this low is there any signs to be
buying okay well these are got one here
you know you got this bar pulling
control towards the bottom that's nice
you've got the Delta is not positive
it's still negative negative 120 - its -
633 and the min Delta so it ate back
some it ate back about I don't know
about 500 okay that's a good sign you
know that's a bit opposite of what you
saw up here you know at this high right
sort of saw the opposite you saw the
positive Delta 600 ended up at 159 then
you get down here right you sort of have
the opposite what was it here you know
633 and - 120 - again that's bullish
right what happens is just goes sideways
and then you get a new low by a tick one
tick okay people say well you know you
made a new low yeah you may know do a
little bit one tick okay say you get
stopped out so you have your stop right
here right so you're buying this you get
stopped out here well here at this next
row again similar thing point control at
the bottom min Delta - 700 699 fishel e
and Delta end up at 126 positive so 1/4
- 700 - positive 126 it's like a swing
of 800 contracts right there again point
of control towards the bottom more
importantly what do you have on this low
1248 15 15 you know you got some support
down here okay Delta scalper comes in
next bar so say you bought this bar you
got stopped out because it made a new
low by a tick right and your stop this
right here if your
using a very type style right for those
low you got stopped out okay forget it
put that one you know put that trade
behind you move on analyze the market
boom you get another buy signal right
here point of control towards the bottom
supportive buying down here 1200 1500
Delta swing 4 - 700 - positive 100 very
bullish signs Delta scalper next bar you
should be looking at these bars to be
getting long again so for what's this
area you know it's around the 47 50 area
what happens your rally from 47 50 you
know all the way up into the 90s 80s 90s
you know then your Cisco sideways
eventually you do go higher into new
highs about 48 bucks okay now you get up
to this high 48 21 what do you got you
know any time you get to the highs you
ask yourself you know are we going to go
higher are we going to sell off no those
are questions you should be posing to
the market you know let the market tell
you what it's going to do now as you're
going up into these highs you got nice
deltas a thousand 126 they're okay but
500 then you get up here on this high
positive 346 and then it's up at
negative 229 okay kind of mixed but you
know I like the way that it's going I
like the direction it's moving but what
he got
you got one balance imbalance -
imbalance three imbalances you got
multiple imbalances in that bar okay
that's a sign you don't see buying
imbalances anymore you're starting to
see selling imbalances next bar stacks
selling them balanced against they got
three imbalances here Delta one from 229
to minus 316 that's again that's a
bearish sign another bearish sign - 563
the green bar okay we'll see what the
next bar is going to turn it to it's red
it's still a strong negative Delta - 400
so at this point you're up here your 4
bars into the high and when you got you
get all negative Delta - 29 3 1 6 563
for force and it's not just like 29 31
56:47 it's it's 200 300 500 400 you know
again that's the market telling you hey
you know we might peel off from this
high here
might move lower and what happens boom
look at this all negative Delta here so
you make this move from you know 4810
yeah where's your stop up here above
forty eight twenty you know assuming
you're getting shorted in this bar
somewhere and you probably realistically
should be getting short somewhere in
this bar but say you're getting short in
this bar 48:12 forty eight ten your
stops up here forty eight twenty to
forty a 23-8 10 tick stop okay so you're
short at forty eight ten what happens
market sells off what does it sell off
down back down into the 60s bar where
you have the delta right is eighty seven
you think Lots it's negative okay but
look at a deeper it went from 634 to
minus eighty seven okay again by now you
should be picking this up right saying
hey you know what there's a shift
internally in this bar and buyers came
in all right we went from negative 634
net sellers to only minus 87 you have
this candle this little bit of a hammer
shape here you know Delta's getting a
little bit weaker technically but it's
all still selling that's all you got 0
max delta 0 max 0 max tom in then men
these are closing right on there mins
but this one is is important it's
telling you the shift it's telling you
that hey you know we've had strong
sellers now what happens we're seeing
aggressive buying and then this next bar
BAM very strong very strong buying
coming in here you've got the Delta
scalper coming in and look look at this
Delta it's positive a thousand you know
it's a strong number for crude and what
happens is you sort of go up and start
to go sideways before you finally get to
move up here you know you got this bar
that's basically all buying imbalances
and you know part the part that unless
he's worried me but the part dote pissed
me off a little bit about this move was
it didn't build on it right you didn't
get another green bar here you just want
sideways in here then you're with this
bar with the ratio point control up near
the top the single print some imbalances
you know you got the Delta surge right
here Delta scalper
this bar here and you know you get this
little bit of a move back down then you
rally back up again are there any signs
in here I mean you can make this
argument right here this four bar
structure for you five to twenty four
thirty eight negative thirty eight and
then positive two twenty three this is
nice this is a nice to see then nice
another positive Delta here let's assign
you seen that the selling weakening and
buying come in like this coming down you
know getting weaker selling weaker
selling buying taking over still buying
coming in and then you put in a little
bit of a rally up here you get up here
to this bar this is ten twenty three
here and again what do you got you got
some strong Delta's here five hundred
seven hundred and then here to twenty
three negative two twenty three again it
was positive four hundred ended up at
minus two hundred again that's a shift
of about 600-700 then say you're not
convinced yet room Delta scalp are
coming in here all negative Delta minus
fourteen sixty min Delta would the bar
close it closed at minus fourteen sixty
right on the moon Delta so close right
on its most negative Delta then you get
this bar here sort of a nothing bar in
terms of Delta minus eighteen this bar
here strong negative Delta five hundred
and what happens so say you're getting
short somewhere you know in this bar or
even being similar towards the game this
bar will call it forty seven eighty
eight somewhere in here you know you get
this move lower down into you know the
high 60s but mostly in the 70s just sort
of going sideways for the rest of the
session you know going into the closer
late in the session you got a little bit
of a sell-off but you know after this
move that was basically about it for the
rest of the day it was not much else and
they're really good to excited about so
yeah that's how you can use Delta didn't
trading right that's you know the
majority of what I talked about here was
was Delta I mean I could I could do
another presentation on imbalances on
crude maybe another time but you know by
now you should be able to understand the
differences between the
doesn't and why they're important in
trading now the other market I want to
talk about really quick put us in peace
if you remember you know like I said
USPS we had the big update it was nice
finally to get get a big update for once
instead of a big down day you know if
you're looking at the you know at the
daily charts right I mean it's just
again you get all these days with these
small ranges well
Candlestick wise it looks like a small
range but some of these you know you're
still talking you know 60 up to 70 so 10
points 10 points 10 points but mostly
getting these you know big down days big
down days you know you get one big
update and when it gets slammed so we'll
see if we get slammed today or tomorrow
tomorrow's Thursday this was a Thursday
the 17th 10th which was also a Thursday
so we'll see if you know we're going to
give it back today or tomorrow but again
you know on a pure candlestick you know
you got this hammer shape form right
here and you can do Forex guy so it's a
pin bar you know the doc about they'll
be posting it all up online it's a pin
bar you got to be buying it right there
it's a no-brainer but you know it is a
bullish bar I'll give it that much it
was nice to get this nice big up you
know decent update I'll say big update
because you know our down days are a lot
bigger than our updates but it's nice to
get that but what were the signs in the
order for early and there were signs
there were signs so let's just sort of
walk it back here a little bit 8:30 is
the cash open you know just before the
cash open you got the Delta scalper
right on the cash open signaling you
know to buy then you get a period Delta
scalp or given a sell this one doesn't
work out it fails now at this time what
you got here you got divergence
divergence divergence so you've already
got three divergences in 15 minutes
another one so you have four they failed
you starting to get these divergences
that are failing and why is that
important you know if you're just
selling every divergence you can get
your head handed to you on a day like
today
but failed divergences are a sign of a
market that's trending you know when you
have a group of them early in the
session watch out watch out when you
start hitting those highs again you know
if they're divergences on the way up if
their cells if the market going low and
you get that Virgin says look for
Cassell and you know so there were
science in here it's at nine you know
nine thirty
you know we're trading twenty four
thirty three and a quarter thirty three
and a half it's you know the signs that
we know that there's a stronger under
undercurrent in the market you know we'd
hit the high sell off a little bit
buying pressure comes back in make a new
high sell off a little bit will come
back up to the highs you know you know
what you want to be doing is it look for
these breakouts you know today was a day
where it wasn't just you know like a
one-way street you'd hit the high and
come off a little bit hit the high and
come off a little bit but again you know
the sign was were there early that
you're going to be going higher with
these failed divergences so you know
there were science behind it around the
43:44 area you know excuse me you know
and we end up rallying all the way up to
you know the 50s you know eventually I
mean when you're getting these signs you
know ratio and divergence and it just
comes right back with a bullish ratio
that's that's not a good sign that this
ratio and divergence is going to work
out you don't want to get the market
come back with a bullish ratio you don't
want that right that's a very bad sign
that it's not going to work out and even
here you're getting some signs you got
ratio and divergence Delta scalper
stacked imbalance everything you want up
at a high to be getting short on and
what happens it doesn't sell off again
that's a sign right understanding that
you have all these barrier signs and the
market is fighting it is it's a sign
that you're still going to go higher
there's still capacity left for this
move higher and you know boom boom boom
we go all the way up still keep going up
up up up you know before eventually we
get up here to 54 at the high of the day
just before the cash closed and then
some selling comes in a little you know
right ahead of the cash closed pop-up
right on the eye right up on the close
close up on our high in the
session right now we're a little bit
lower I'm not too surprised to see a
little bit of a little bit of selling in
the session but that was one of the
signs right the failed divergences you
know all the bear signs early and the
market just hollering right through them
now another another sign op scrunch this
chart don't worry about the order flow
what you're looking at is this the
volume profile now another sign earlier
in the day we had our point of control
down here I'm going to run with this
price school is called 34 then as they
started developing he started migrating
higher a new higher point of control up
here around the 42 43 area so you're you
know you're getting you know it's this
was about nine something here you're
getting a new higher point of control so
you're ready getting your point control
is migrating higher a little bit later
you got a higher point control up coming
in here around the 46 area so you got
three higher point controls
already that's what a sign that some
sign of a market that's going to start
you know that's rallying right you put
in a higher point controls so after you
put in the the new higher point of
control you got the second higher point
of control does that make sense so you
had your first point of control then you
got a second point of control chances
are if you start trading higher you're
going to put in a higher point of
control if you start breaking down to
that value area high of this area you're
going to put in another point of control
up here at you know what is this
24:51 and a quarter is your point of
control for the day you know so right
now we're just right you know in the
next session again you know this is that
line 51 and a quarter the next session
you know where are we were just a little
bit lower below your previous date point
of control
well you're still around your your day's
point of control right now in the
evening session okay just really quick
we'll talk about the Aussie dollar again
an Aussie dollar I don't really talk
about that much I said but it's one of
those contracts it's just a slow mover
sometimes if you could position yourself
right it trends nicely now you know I
like that you came down in here in the
early morning European session took off
the lows you got the sound imbalance
below the low
me that's more of a bearish sign as the
sound imbalance just above the lows I
like it below but you get down here you
got the Delta scalper given a buy this
one doesn't work out it fails on you
pretty quick and then you know we hit
this low nothing in here really didn't
get too excited about buying but then up
here you had a nice couple of things
right this red bar is the price rejector
you got a bearish ratio you got negative
Delta you got the Delta scalper given a
sell and you had a nice move back down
to you know close to the lows before
closing you know somewhere around the 70
909 area so you know wasn't a monster
move you know wasn't like a hundred tick
move or anything like that but it was a
decent move to have to have caught there
I want to show you guys the buttons if I
could just find that bun chart i screen
shot it and I went and closed the actual
chart quite pissed if I did but I think
I did close it shucks
it's just my eyes my eyes deceive me
this is a beautiful trading opportunity
this morning in the buns okay so you
know you open up here
Chicago time one o'clock let me sell off
right on the low you got Delta scalper
give it a buy what happens is a rally no
kind of just goes sideways for a while
and then boom get down here at this low
164 12 what do you got you got a bullish
ratio you've got a divergence single
print you got some buying imbalances
coming in next bar a couple more buying
imbalances but you should already be
thinking getting along in here around
the sixteen seventeen eighteen level
definitely below twenty even if you're
late coming in here in this bar here
around the twenty level what happens we
rally rally all the way up back up to
our highs back up into the 40s and make
new highs up here with the forty six but
who cares if this was the move to be had
in the this morning in the buns right
here from your low up to your high up
here you got a ratio but no divergence
here you got you know this it's set up
perfectly that's how you want it those
are the trades you want to be taken you
know those I said you know if I said if
there's only one or two things you use
in order flow use the use the which
we'll call it use the ratio and
divergence this really quick is Delta
scalp right on the Dow it's a hundred
very fast moving chart I'm just curious
to see how it look you know it's okay
you know you got some nice trades in
here some decent moves you know from
forty five all the way up or you get the
signals you know it's a sixty sixty tick
move there some false signals not really
working out here here here although
these just like this one you shouldn't
be taken because you know I like to let
the market take me in you look for
another look for a little bit look for a
move just because you've got the red bar
you know look you know you put your you
should be looking to get in if we
continue in the next bar not just rally
back up but still there's some decent
moves here we had you know some little
bit moves again it's a hundred tick
charts so you're this is one you're
you're in and out in and out in and out
in and out short-term trading not
something you're necessarily going to be
home
unless you get it unless you catch the
trend early now the yen just really
quick on the Delta scalper you know
early morning not much going on here
then boom you get a nice seller around
the 65 area you know again it trades
down to the 40s get this other grouping
of cells right here sell sell sell other
things telling you to stay short stay
short in here so you're initially you're
short from up here you do rally back up
again back but you get in signs up here
to stay shorts get short stay short and
what happens is you just sell off the
rest of the morning the rest of the
afternoon right now we're in the Asian
session
you got to buy right off the low okay
and then you get another buyer say this
one they get long here it stops you out
boom it comes right back you know from
30 all the way up to you know the 45
area where you got this cell right now
so you know there were some decent
decent trading opportunities in the
currencies actually yesterday I think
they were better than than the SPS it
was you know yesterday in the ESPYs is
even though we did have a nice move
higher it was really a bit of a grind is
kind of disappointing in that sense you
know me I like the moves fast
I like I'm big like this you know
straight down I don't like it were just
sort of poke tire comes off poke tire
comes off poke tire comes off
lastly I'll talk about five years really
quick just because it's kind of a boring
session in the fives and it was a sign
early that it might be a boring session
this morning here at you know between
2:00 and 5:00 you put in a shitload of
volume here at 1:18 16 see this
imbalance eleven thousand I like that we
popped up then we came right down
through it really quick like butter you
didn't have the buy in there anymore so
again I was curiously what's going to
happen when we come back up to the 16
level so I drew that line and what
happens is you get there you still got
volume this is now during the u.s.
session and actually you put in more
volume down here at 15 and a half so I
felt you know if you're just going to
hang around 16 excuse me
you know here we spent three hours
trading in this one bar I was afraid
that if we start hanging around 16 again
and the volume reappears we're going to
spend the rest of the day around there
and and actually you know from 8 until
11 basically we're trading between you
know 15 and a half and 16 right here
before eventually you know selling off
staying below fifteen and a half and
coming down into a new low but again
they oh this isn't any great trade it
was just something we're just sort of
hanging around this area here putting in
a shitload of volume you know 57,000 was
your new point of control here at
fifteen and a half
you still had 47,000 up here at at
sixteen you could just see all these
pointed controls basically lining up
since you know 823 until you know until
what is that 1120 so for three hours
you're just putting in all our opponent
controls putting in our days going to
control you know in this area right here
at fifteen and a half so it's a little
bit lower you know to tick slower but
you know that was assigned to me that
hey you know we could have a boring
session in the in the fives you know I
was excited about this at 7:54 the ratio
and divergence ratio in the bar
afterwards but then again it's just one
just went dead on you flatline basically
four hundred three point controls at the
same level one above one below which is
essentially the same so now this this
trade didn't work out as well as you'd
like but again you say you're minded in
here at fifteen maybe you're selling it
at sixteen so you're getting you know
four tix what do you do but hey it's
better than a poke in the eye so thanks
for watching this video to learn more
about order flow visit order flows or go
learn what about the Delta scalper go to
Delta scalper comm so thanks and have a
good day everyone
bye-bye